President
Andrzej Duda has been President of Poland for almost 10 years
I think he should know
How it works in the United States
or an election campaign anywhere
He should not meet the candidate.
who runs in elections
because it is perceived as
Support for this candidate
And I think this is a meeting with a presidential candidate.
Mr.
Trump and former President
The United States was unfortunate.
No matter what they were talking about.
He went there as head of state.
and went to dinner in a private apartment
Donald Trump
Former President
You don't do that,
Mr. Editor.
This is completely irresponsible.
non-typomatic
President Andrzej Duda said
that he learns all the time
But for almost 10 years
learned very little
When it comes to this end